Clark Kellogg from CBS joins us I you
know I it's weird because these guys are
younger than me yeah but the impact
Georgetown had on a different generation
do you remember what that was like when
you first realized what John Thompson
had with Patrick the early 80s they're
banged heads again shootout oh as a
member of the Ohio State Buckeyes back
in 82 Patrick was a freshman we found a
way to beat him by a point where you and
Tim was there any intimidation factor so
how old were you when you're playing
patty I was a junior okay was a freshman
when you get between those lines then oh
it's hard to admit to being intimidated
by anybody and as a junior I just don't
know if there was any freshman even if
it was Patrick Ewing that was gonna
intimidate me to where I would admit it
okay yeah but people don't realize how
great a basketball player you were at
Ohio State but when you're you know
facing these teams younger players you
know sometimes you can think more about
it than you need to instead of just
going out there playing because there
was high paranoia like they were creel
as a matter of fact I left after my
junior year and 82 Patrick went on to
have his Hall of Fame career both in
college and the pros so as I watched
those Georgetown teams and coach
Thompson in particular in terms of what
he represented how they went about their
work and how successful they were it was
a source of pride for me as a young
african-american man to see coach
Thompson doing what he was doing the way
he was and not only on the court but
really lifting his players up to
appreciate and embrace education and how
they carried themselves and now I get
the privilege of sitting next to coach
Thompson as part of the Westwood one
coverage of the Final Four for the last
few years so full circle for me but I
remember those teams quite fondly from a
distance when I was up against
I'm trying to beat a little I'm a
distance great admiration and respect
did you play against Berkeley in college
not in college we banged heads when he
was with the Sixers and I was two years
into my broker and I tell you this day
and I played a game against Charles
Barkley and got the better of him and
the way that the MBAs got to work
sometimes you play that same team within
a week and that after we I had gotten
the best of him in that first meeting we
met them again within seven days and he
was waiting for me he came at me so hard
I was double ice packed after the game
wait why was he coming it was because he
was a player that he I was a player that
he had looked up to somewhat because he
was a couple years behind me and I think
that first meeting maybe he was a little
bit deer in the headlights he's told me
this story so I'm sharing it from his
perspective so when he realized that I
gotten the best of him I think he wanted
a piece of me real bad
the next time and he put it on pretty
good you faced a young Michael Jordan -
yeah I did and at that time the Bulls
and Pacers were actually fairly
competitive in other words neither one
of us were making the playoffs and we
always felt that we could beat them and
they could beat us and you could see his
greatness even then at that point he was
young a couple years behind me but in
many people's eyes the greatest of all
time you just lost a fan there I think
yeah literally a fan yeah yeah it's a
real fan yeah real fan
do you have a Larry Bird story yeah it's
similar to what happened with Barkley
you know Larry's from Indiana one's the
Indiana State played for the Celtics and
the only time we would really have a
great crowd that Market Square Arena
back in those days is when the Celtics
or Lakers came in and so we had kind of
gotten the best of the Celtics in a
prior meeting and then we had that quick
turnaround and I wasn't the only guy
guarding him but he proceeded to give us
give us give us 53 and told us about
most of them as he was as he was giving
them out so I do again that was probably
the the
the best memory I have of bird we struck
we beat him pretty we handled him at
Market Square and then within a week ten
days we had to go to the famed Boston
Garden and he was waiting for us - but
you're such a nice guy why would Larry
talk trash to you I think Larry is a guy
who does not discriminate - dealing with
the opponent no matter who you are what
you are he's about taking you down and
letting you know about it in the process
suddenly smartly but sharply as a matter
of fact very few people realized that
Larry did talk when he played he was
just so discrete with it that it was
hard for the average fan to pick up on
it one of my favorite stories there's so
many great stories that you hear from
these guys after the fact bird refuses
refused to acknowledge Dan Majerle
because Marley's a rookie and he doesn't
talk to rookies so he says to mark West
what he's going to do tomorrow late but
he's not gonna tell Marley because he's
not worthy of my words because he's a
rookie classic I love that and me Xavier
McDaniel one where he think they call a
timeout and he says hey X I'm gonna I'm
gonna get the ball here and I'm gonna
take a jumper and then we're gonna win
the game all right you know he just told
me what they're gonna do bird gets the
ball takes a shot jumper wins the game
and you go I told y'all gonna do that
okay
it's amazing when you can back it up as
much as he did okay is it fair can we
have the conversation about LeBron and
Michael Jordan what direction do you
want to go but can LeBron ever get above
Michael Jordan above yeah I don't know
if he can or not and some people's minds
yes and others no it's a wonderful
debate for me personally I look at
LeBron sighs athletics
speed skill and he's on par in my mind
as a basketball player and even even
closing in on his iconic status as an
influencer and impact therefore good
much of what LeBron has done on the
court I think is probably gonna pale in
comparison to the impact that he has on
the lives of other people through his
philanthropy through his activism I just
think he's one of those special special
people that comes along every generation
but is he a better all-around player
than Jordan well I go back to something
my dad told me before he passed he
talked about it all the time he said all
things being equal if you've got a guy
who's a little bigger usually he'll beat
the smaller guy who's just as good
LeBron is six eight to whatever 5060
extra yeah whatever I mean whatever it
is it's huge I don't think there's
anything athletically that Michael does
or did better than LeBron and in
basketball parlance and skill set you
look at passing ball handling shooting
rebounding leading I mean you can go
down that you could just whatever
criteria you'd be hard-pressed to say
other than two championships and this is
not tennis or golf there's a team
component to winning championships not
to disparage anything Michael did but
there's a team component there are a lot
of great players in a team sport that
don't get rings but our champions they
aren't championship holders but they're
champions because of how they've
competed what their level of excellence
has been over a period of time so when
you just look at basketball skillset
passing I give the nod to LeBron
brilliant genius passer unparalleled
outside of bird
Rick Barry
those are the only four words I think of
that see a frame ahead the way LeBron
does shooting probably Michael better
looking shot yeah but in terms of
results driving it I mean you go down
the list it's a great debate and again I
defer to my late dad
good big / good smaller if you have to
choose so collect call it Kellogg has
just said that LeBron is a better player
than Michael okay my bad I thought I
think I think Patrick did you did you
hear what Clark does sent their own
opinion you know LeBron is a great
player but then it sound like he took
LeBron over Michael has over over and
that's that killer instinct LeBron is a
great player you can't take anything
away from him he's achieved everything
that he's one of chief with the
basketball he can do a lot of different
things like you said he is for a person
his size to be able to do the things
that he can do is remarkable he can pass
he can shoot he can see a frame ahead he
can fly in the air and do all the things
that he can do and a four player for a
player who plays the center position I
would love to be able to play with a
player like him because he's going to
give me the ball
you know but Mike Michael has that
killer instinct and I think that LeBron
learned he's learnt it over the years
he's worked it over the years we'll get
to more from Patrick coming up here by
the way he wore his Georgetown uniform
that he applied in that if you're
watching or not watching on TV Patrick
came with his Georgetown uniform on
those were the really short shorts back
but now they're coming back all right
here's the question for you Clark
Kellogg if Loyola wins the national
title historically how are we gonna
treat this would it be one of the great
great stories in the history of the
tournament but what's a bigger better
story in terms of historically well
Texas El Paso to me yeah okay is a is a
is a bigger story a different story a
different project the significance is
because of the social impact yes at that
and actually the sixty-three loyal the
Ramblers team was a bit of a forerunner
to the Texas Western squad for
african-american players starting Jerry
Harkness yeah who has Pacers history and
who I've gotten to know over the years
because of my relationship with the
Pacers franchise that too has story and
you tie in the Texas Western yeah upset
over Kentucky so I think in some ways
the social significance different
clearly different because of the
landscape and the times and the issues
but in terms of magnitude of journey
you'd be hard-pressed to put any other
tournaments to Georgetown of 85 perhaps
but even that one would be different
than this one
my strong would say outside of those 63
66 be hard-pressed to come up with one
that would top it beyond those two
I still think people misidentified the
Villanova
upset of Georgetown is the greatest
upset because Villanova was a whole lot
better than people thought and the fact
that they had played Georgetown twice
and played him close I believe in both
of those games during the regular season
I just they played a perfect game but I
don't think Villanova was that far
beneath Georgetown as a complete team
agree but Loyola is not that far behind
these teams in the final no I think that
they can bake and stand up to Michigan
right now that's a different discussion
yes but in terms of how they did it when
they did it who they did it against that
Villanova upset is still monumental
because 90% or more of the folks thought
they had no chance yeah those even in
basketball circles knew that the
familiarity would help them but I would
guess that if you took the survey of the
coaches during that time or those in the
know it would have still been an
overwhelming tilt towards Georgetown
prevailing so I think that still rates
as one of the great upsets clearly in
the tournament's history are you a
minister I am an ambassador for Christ
okay but you it feels like you but
because I think this is your flock right
here I'm always representing who lives
inside of me and that's Jesus Christ
through our faith so that comes out
hopefully oh no I can hear hopefully
that comes out easy ease up on the
handshake though ease up a little bit I
get a little lighter yeah I'd rather
give a little doubt next time I get my
hands a nice right back but here yes
Paul Clarke got me - he went Adrian
Peterson in my hand yeah Adrian Peterson
can hurt you
well if you've ever spent time around
the late great Mel Daniels another
iconic player with the Indiana Pacers if
you didn't go in there strong mmm you
wouldn't get out oh okay so I just I'm
just carrying that with me how about I
just wave to you when you leave I'm not
quite Kellogg from CBS in Westwood one
always great to see it
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]